what's going on
humanoids i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message for today
february 8th 2021
and before we get into anything and
today is a a wide-eyed
varied show on all sorts of topics that
i think you're going to enjoy i'm
looking forward to chatting with you
but before we do that we have to do a
little bit of housekeeping
here i've got to clean something up that
happened on
thursday now you know on friday we did
our panel show
on spirituality and meaning amidst the
chaos these days which a lot of you guys
enjoyed and we're going to keep doing
those
but on thursday i was doing a regular
direct message and i began the show
by saying what's shaken nazis and a lot
of you did find that funny
a lot of you did find that funny what's
shaken nazis i don't know that that's a
phrase that's been said before it seemed
like a funny way to start the show but
then a few of you did say to me well
wait a minute dave
it can't be that all of your audience is
nazis sure there's nazis everywhere
right nazis are in the government
nazis are in the educational institutes
nazis are across
society they're coming for everybody but
what are the chances that
everybody who watches the reuben report
is a nazi i mean it can't be so what do
we do well you know
these days you've got to follow the
science right you've got to go
to where the data is where the numbers
are that's the only way to make sense of
anything
so we looked we looked at the analytics
we
opened up the files okay we went in
we had our math guy there our accountant
the whole reuben report team
and we dug into the numbers to figure
out who's watching
this show okay because i don't want to
say what's shaking nazis the implication
being you're all nazis if it's not the
case
so we looked at the numbers and i want
to update you uh
on what we figured out so it turns out
that
only 60 of you watching right now
are nazis 60 that's it
if i would have just guessed i would
have said around 85 percent
nazi right i do i talk about free speech
a lot you know free markets capitalism
competition
law and order individual rights i would
have thought around 85 nazi
turns out 60 nazi so let's put that
there
uh then it turns out that another 20
of you are capitalist pigs so 60
nazi uh 20 capitalist pigs so that's
about 80 percent of you right there
then we've got 10 anarchists um
that that didn't surprise me these are
the mad max fury road kind of people
just want to disassemble the whole thing
i i appreciate that that gets us to 90
then 10 soyboy i was surprised
i was you know i know that we've still
got a couple you know progressive
lefties that watched the show
did not realize that it would be ten
percent and then of course uh 10
classical liberal you know i wrote a
book defending classical liberalism
i i believe that classical liberalism is
the correct lens
to view the world at least at a
political level
uh to free the most people um so that
doesn't surprise me that's ten percent
now if you add up all of those
percentages we had sixty percent
nazi twenty percent capitalist pig ten
percent anarchist ten percent soy 10
classical liberal you may note that that
comes to a hundred
and ten percent and that's true uh
because this is a big show
this is a big show here and we've got a
lot of people watching and it's
uh very exciting and speaking of big
show uh don't forget guys
click that subscribe button would you
because a lot of you are getting
unsubscribed every time i say it click
it
then people go oh wait a minute i didn't
realize i thought i was subscribed
subscribed and i'm not actually
subscribed so click it make sure you're
getting notified
and all that good stuff and as i said
we've got
a great show for you today and i
wouldn't just say that the way like
conan o'brien or
uh is he even on tv anymore i'm not even
sure or cold he's not maybe he is who
knows
or colbert so we've got a great show for
you tonight here are three actors you
don't care about to lecture what a
racist nazi pig you are uh i'm not
saying it that way i'm saying we've got
a really great show for you today
and before we get to it people do you
know what i want to talk to you about
that's right it's not bilbar it's built
bar emphasis on the tea it's february
people and if you're looking forward to
valentine's day but not sure how to stay
away from the candy
i've got just the solution for you built
bar is the secret
i'll hold two of them at one time to
eating healthier food while also eating
tastier
food am i holding them up properly no
here we go let's do it this way
uh bilt bars are low calorie low sugar
high protein
high fiber great for the keto diet i can
actually lose or maintain weight while
indulging
in a yummy treat healthy has never been
this delicious build bars taste like
candy and they come in 18 amazing
flavors including caramel brownie
and peanut butter bill bars are covered
100
chocolate include both nut and nut free
flavors and are soft and easy to chew
and i know with restaurants opening up
it'll be tempting to indulge but we also
need to shed those additional
additional quarantine pounds which is
why built bars are the perfect
alternative
for the each bar contains 110 to 160
calories 16 to 20 grams of protein three
to five net carbs
it's only february guys don't give up on
your new year's resolution just yet
built bar is the answer go to
builtbar.com and use promo code ruben to
get 20
off your next order use promo code ruben
to get 20
off at builtbar.com and now back to me
all right so i'm psyched to do this
first story because if you want
something i thought we could lead the
show today
with just how stupid is everything and
why it is that we should not be paying
attention to the people that are making
everything so stupid this is the perfect
story to illustrate that
just that uh there was video that went
viral over the last couple days
of ibram ex candy now this
is one of the guys who's been the main
drivers
of sort of pushing all of this woke
intersectionality stuff on us this
critical race theory stuff
this idea that america is evil and
racist
and that it's not that you just have to
be not racist you have to be actively
anti-racist and you're not going to
believe this guys that usually turns out
to you being racist
uh he's written many books on racism can
we throw up some of the books right
there
let's get some of the titles of some of
the books that he's written the one he's
really known for right now is how to be
an
anti-racist and in effect that means you
should be a modern racist
he also wrote stamped racism anti-racism
and you
he wrote stamped from the beginning the
history the definitive history of racist
ideas in america he wrote a children's
book called
anti-racist baby and he also wrote a
book called
the black campus movement these are all
interesting books that
every correspondent on msnbc has behind
them in their fancy bookshelf
but the reason i mention him uh because
obviously i talk a lot about
these issues one of the key parts of how
leftism has become so crazy is the idea
of intersectionality
the idea that you would take all of
these supposed
oppressed groups so you would take black
people
and trans people and gay people and
people with a limp and people with a
lazy eye
and fat people and you would take all of
these people and you could sort of
combine them into one stronger thing
you may remember the constructicons they
were decepticons in the transformers
they were trucks that could combine into
devastator and then they were stronger
as devastator or voltron might be a
reference that would work for you a
similar idea
as the constructicons that's sort of
what they think intersectionality is we
will take all of you
sort of small groups of oppressed people
we will combine you
into one huge thing and what that would
mean is that of course that your
oppressions then
would all be sort of stronger together
but of course
it doesn't work and not only does it not
work it puts people in this hierarchy
that we've talked about as my
friend faisal al-muttara calls the
oppression olympics
where you have to figure out whose
oppression is more than anyone else's
depression so black people are oppressed
this much muslims this much
this much and of course white christian
people especially heterosexual white
christians the most evil of all people
they're always on the bottom of this
thing
anyway why do i mention all of this well
this video went
viral over the weekend this is ibrahim x
candy
the man who wants you to be anti-racist
and woke and progressive and
intersectional
talking about his son and trans issues
let's take a look you know obviously
talking about race even
talking about gender you know i think it
was last week
my daughter came home and said she
wanted to be a boy
you know which was horrifying uh for
my wife to hear myself to hear and so of
course
you know we're like okay what
affirmative message is about girlhood
you know can we be teaching her to
protect her
from whatever she's hearing in our home
or even outside of our home
that would make her want to be a boy um
and i suspect it's the same thing with
you know kids of color in which they're
regularly hearing these messages that
maybe
may want them to want to be white um or
even white children who are like i'm
happy i'm white
right you know what affirmative messages
are are we teaching them to to break
down those ideas
all right so let's just be very clear
here like without equivocation
that guy is a total fraud the entire
concept of woke intersectionality is
totally fraudulent
and and based basically in a bunch of
people who don't believe
the bile that they're constantly spewing
they don't even believe it enough
to put it in their own homes he says
that when his daughter
came home saying she wanted to be a boy
that it was horrifying it was horrifying
for him and his wife why would she quote
want to be a boy now that's a very odd
thing i thought
these movements are together right black
trans lives matter
guess what i believe black trans lives
matter i believe all lives matter i
believe police lives matter i believe
white people's lives matter i know
controversial stuff
but what this guy is saying is he was
horrified
that his own daughter might be trans now
where is the mob
i am fairly certain that if someone on
the right
if tucker carlson let's say that this uh
ibram
kendy is a is a thought leader on the
left he is right this is the stuff that
is being peddled constantly
all over the left okay this is
mainstream acceptance
uh so he's a thought leader on the left
and he just said he would be horrified
that or is horrified in effect that his
daughter came home wanting to be a boy
which is a sort of offensive uh
definition of what trans means that they
just decided that they would suddenly be
a boy
i thought that was offensive but okay
let's put that aside now let's pretend
tucker carlson you know tucker carlson
he's got this little show on fox it's
actually the
highest rated cable news show in all of
television history
imagine if tucker carlson went on air
tonight
and said that his daughter came home and
wanted to be a boy and that he and his
wife were horrified
do you think there'd be calls for
boycotts do you think they'd try to
cancel tucker and possibly this would be
the one that would actually break him
do you guys see the level of hypocrisy
and nonsense
i actually i agree in a certain sense
with ibrahim
in that if your child came home and said
they they wanted to be
a different gender than they are or they
felt that they were a different gender
than they are
then you've got some serious stuff to
work out maybe you would find out that
they were trans perhaps
but if this is a young child i think his
child's like five or six years old if
i'm not mistaken um
there's a lot of time that you have to
play with there but even even saying
that that you don't allow
i'm sorry that his daughter is five or
six years old um
even if you don't allow uh
you know children to immediately say oh
i'm trans and then immediately start
getting therapy
they'll now call you a bigot right we
all know this i did uh i did
an interview with abigail schreier who
wrote a book all about this about young
girls transitioning very young
anyway the point of this is that the
people who are pushing this nonsense
they don't believe it themselves the
people who push
intersectionality don't believe it and
the people who push can't
cancel culture it's not because they
want to cancel people across the board
who have bad ideas it's because they
want to cancel
other people you know damn well like you
just know it in your bones if tucker
carlson said this
if ben shapiro said this if dave rubin
said this
there would be calls to get them booted
off youtube have fox news canceled take
out the daily wire sponsors
whatever it might be but here's a good
lefty who's obviously by their
definition he's a transphobe
he has a a phobia is an irrational fear
it seems to me
that uh he has an irrational fear of
trans people
his daughter came home and said she
wanted to be a boy and he said it was
horrifying that seems like an irrational
fear
if we are supposed to believe that trans
people are wonderful and great and
everything else and again
i believe they should live whatever life
they want to live
but by his own logic by the logic of the
left by the rules
that they demand you play by while you
while they don't play by them themselves
well then here we are so that person
should not be i'm not calling for his
cancellation
people can still buy his books he's not
going away that's okay
but we should understand that he's a
fraud and that the idea of
intersectionality
is completely fraudulent as well i think
you got the point there did you get the
point there i think you got the point
uh let's talk about expressvpn for just
a moment you know ever since the new
year i've been talking about expressvpn
on my show i'm doing it right now
why haven't you got vpn yet guys maybe
you thought hey this is america and we
have free speech and privacy laws
and so you hesitated perhaps you believe
that trump and congress wouldn't allow
big tech to censor and spy on you
so you didn't act well ladles and jelly
spoons people love when i say that i'll
tell you this with the new
administration and cancel culture raging
out of control there's never been a more
important time to protect your digital
rights
that's why so many patriotic listeners
are choosing to secure their online data
by using expressvpn i use it myself
do you believe that a vpn isn't for you
because you can use the internet just
fine without one well sadly that's just
no longer true
with the recent actions taken by big
tech to control our digital lives
are you confused about how it works
expressvpn is an app for computers and
smartphones
that encrypts your network data and
reroutes it through a secure server that
means
that you can use the internet more
anonymously without having your activity
tracked
do you think that vpns are complex and
only for tech experts take it from me
they're not with expressvpn you launch
the app and literally tap one button and
you protect yourself that's it
it's time to trust expressvpn to protect
your online data because they're rated
number one
and they stand for your values now is
the time for you
to take a stance take back your privacy
to expressvpn.com
ruben that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
ruben to get three months free
expressvpn.com
ruben right now and now back to me all
right
well i should say before we do this
story that i could be canceled right
this could be the one
this if the stream goes down in the
middle of this one uh
it's very possible and it was nice
knowing all of you and you should
join me at reubenreport.locals.com
because obviously i'm going to be booted
off all of this stuff at some point and
that at least
i own it and i can communicate directly
with you guys uh but this is
actually a completely insane story i i
know that i say a lot of things are
bananas
i know i've brought bananas back into
the vernacular right
um but this one is truly truly bananas
so time magazine which used to be a
pretty reputable place of journalism and
it's actually not all terrible
uh they released an article in the last
couple days called the secret
history of the shadow campaign that
saved the 2020 election now let's just
let me just repeat that title there
because as you know youtube has said
we're not allowed to talk about
uh election security we're not allowed
to talk about conspiracy things related
to all of this and if we are to talk
about any of those things our channel
could
we could get a strike which basically
means you can't live stream and they
could just they could just delete your
channel
and it is only by the grace of these
good people that
any of us are here but we've been told
we can't talk about this stuff and then
time magazine which is a mainstream i
suppose
a reputable source they wrote a piece
again called the secret
history of the shadow campaign that
saved the 2020 election
orwell would be proud of that title
himself uh so i want to read you some of
the quotes
from this this is actually remarkable
what they're saying here and again i
just want to say
these these conspiracy theories i'm
about to read are from time
magazine and that dave rubin is but a
humble servant who is just
reading words from something else so
please
susan wajesky and youtube overlords
don't delete me i'm just
reading word for word what they said in
time magazine and you guys
will make some decisions on your own
this is what they say
this is the inside story of the
conspiracy
to save the 2020 election based on
access
to the group's inner workings
never-before-seen documents and
interviews with
dozens of those involved from across the
political spectrum
there was a conspiracy unfolding behind
the scenes one that both curtailed the
protests
and coordinated coordinated the
resistance
from ceos both surprises were the result
of an
informal alliance between left-wing
activists
and business titans the pact was
formalized in a terse
little noticed joint statement of the
u.s chamber of commerce
the afl-cio published on election day
both sides would come to see it as a
sort of implicit
bargain inspired by the summer's massive
sometimes destructive
racial justice protests in which the
forces of labor came together with the
forces of capital
to keep the peace and oppose trump's
assault on democracy come back to me for
one second here
i'm going to read a little bit more but
but are you are you getting this so far
the forces of business came together
with the forces of
left-wing activist groups to protect
our democracy i don't want to
editorialize too much again i
i love you youtube thank you for letting
me be here you're wonderful people
all of you um but i'm just reading what
they say here and i just wanted to give
you a little context
let's continue though the scenario the
shadow campaigners
shadow campaigners were desperate to
stop was not a trump victory
it was an election so calamitous that no
result could be discerned at all
a failure of the central act of
democratic self-governance
that has been a hallmark of america
since its founding i will editorialize
for a moment yes yes
they didn't it wasn't that they wanted
to stop trump they just wanted to make
sure
that the election would be okay you get
it that was it
these these are completely non-partisan
left-wing activists and business leaders
but they just want to make sure you get
the truth okay let's continue
their work touched every aspect of the
election they got states to change
voting systems what
and laws and helped secure hundreds of
millions in public and private funding
they fended off voter suppression
lawsuits recruited armies of poll
workers
and got millions of people to vote by
mail for the first time
they successfully pressured social media
companies to take
a harder line against disinformation and
use data-driven
strategies to fight viral smears they
executed
national public awareness campaigns that
helped americans
understand how the vote count would
unfold over days or weeks preventing
trump's conspiracy theories
and false claims of victory from getting
more traction after election day they
monitored every pressure point to ensure
that trump
could not overturn the result
well you know i don't really have
anything to say about all that
that's time magazine telling you that a
secret cabal of people
got together with left-wing activists
and big business groups in the afl-cio
and uh they did what's best for you and
uh
if you don't believe that they did
what's best for you you're
uh suffering from misinformation and you
should probably
check in to your local reprogramming
center or your local gulag
generally you do the reprogramming
center first and if it doesn't take you
go to the google app but if you want to
go straight to the google app i'm sure
that can be arranged as well
again i have nothing to add to that
that's an article in
time magazine and it's a wonderful place
of journalism and
in essence they're saying that a secret
cabal of people
uh did everything they can to protect
the election and get the result that
they wanted
um but it wasn't because they certainly
wanted a particular person to win is
just because they're really
great people who are defending america
and we should all accept that
and i do because you know
guys guys got to make a living you know
so okay
good talk everybody let me talk to you
about gabby insurance
everybody we're all looking for ways to
save money right especially now so let
me ask you this
how'd you like to keep an extra 900
bucks 961 dollars actually
in your pocket that's how much gabby
customers save per year on average
on car and home insurance gabby takes
the pain out of shopping for insurance
by giving you
an apples to apples comparison of your
current coverage with 40 of the top
insurance providers like progressive
nationwide
and travelers just link your current
insurance account and in minutes you'll
be able to see quotes for the exact same
coverage you currently have
it's fast and it's easy and gabby can
show you if you've been overpaying i
discovered great deals as well as new
insurance companies
and was quickly able to compare the top
five rates by seeing them listed in
order which made navigating through the
plan super easy like i mentioned earlier
gabby customers save 961 dollars
on average i bet that'd be pretty decent
to have in your pocket right now
if they can't find you savings they'll
let you know so you can relax knowing
that you have the best rate
out there and they never sell your info
so no annoying spam or robo calls
you're probably overpaying on car and
home insurance see how much gabby can
save you it's totally free to check
and there's no obligation go to gabi.com
ruben that's gabi.com
reuben g-a-b-i gabby dot com slash
reuben and now back to me okay so i'm
super psyched actually to do this
this next little segment and i'm gonna
do a lot more of these whether you like
it or not because
well not because whether you like or not
i know you're going to like it and
that's why i'm going to do more of them
i've already committed to my people
doing one of them every day this week
because i think something interesting is
brewing here so as you guys know i don't
really watch
sports anymore i love sports
particularly i love basketball
i haven't watched the nba in about a
season and a half i just don't need to
be
watching a bunch of millionaires lecture
me about things and see black lives
matter on the court and i just don't
care about it anymore i watch old
basketball games on youtube
i watch old comedies on youtube i don't
really there's very little that's out on
netflix right now i feel like i've seen
everything i watch seinfeld
i watch like a lot of old stuff and i
think in many ways that keeps me
connected to the world that used to
exist and a lot of the stuff right now
it's like i just don't feel like giving
these people my money or attention or
anything else
anyway although i did watch the super
bowl yesterday and i pretty much muted
it during all the depressing commercials
because it was like they're they're
basically just telling you how to live
your life it's like are you selling me a
car
are you selling me a dorito are you
telling me how to live actually the
dorito commercial was fine but like
you know you get it it's like every
commercial oh everything's horrible
it's like okay do you make a product
maybe i'll buy it
um anyway when i'm doing cardio i
usually watch old basketball games but
some of the other things that i've been
doing i've been watching
just sort of 60s and 70s and 80s
sometimes talk shows
sometimes with political leaders just to
kind of remember what things used to be
like
and i happen to come across this clip
it's about 18 minutes in total we're
just going to show you about a minute
and a half right now but then
for the rest of the week i'm going to
show you more clips from it
this is uh ronald reagan who at the time
had just ended being governor the
republican governor
my he was really a moderate republican
governor of california
this is 1975 he's on the tonight show
with johnny carson and this is a sort of
sidebar
but if you want to just see the
difference between the late night shows
of today
versus the brilliant exquisite elegant
professional that johnny carson was well
you'll see it in just a second and just
notice the difference
in tone and tenor and everything else
but anyway ronald reagan is obviously a
conservative he is obviously a
republican
he's obviously on the right as i said he
was the republican governor of
california
this is 1975 before he had officially
decided
to run for president uh and then he
obviously became president in 1980 after
jimmy carter for four years and then he
was president
for eight years but there was so much in
this
video that he says that is true today
and when you realize that things were
true in 1975 that were true today
and guess what there were truths in 1975
that were true in 1960 and everything
else
i just thought it was a great way of
linking a little bit of the past
to the present and the point is that
things that
are eternally true they're true no
matter what year it is so this is ronald
reagan
on the johnny carson tonight show
talking about the role of government
back in 1975 well
johnny i think that one of the things is
that people keep looking to government
for the answer and government's the
problem
you a moment ago you you asked you know
about
people and feeling not only confused but
right low and and down in america
first of all the american people if they
would just take a little inventory and
look around
you triple our troubles and we're better
off than any other people on earth
and we've asked so much of government
and we've gotten in the habit over the
last forty years of thinking the
government has the answers
there's very little that government can
do as efficiently and as economically as
the people can do themselves and if
government would shut the doors and
sneak away for about three weeks we'd
never miss them
okay i would like to announce that i
will be running
a gofundme and what we're going to be
doing is we're going to
crowdsource a whole bunch of money and
then i would like to reanimate the
corpse of ronald reagan
that's the guy that we need as president
of the united states those are the ideas
we need and it's not just
of course what he's talking about about
the government has gotten too big and
that there's nothing the government
can do that people can't do better on
them on their own
it's that he has a mastery of the ideas
the pleasant way that he speaks
actually as i said we're gonna do uh
three more clips of this this week and
maybe i'll keep doing this i
this this concept maybe will be a
further segment as we go along with the
show
but the pleasant demeanor uh the humor
that he brings in much of it
um the understanding of the proper
issues and having like
an actual philosophy that we understand
as opposed
to all virtually all of the politicians
right now that you don't know what their
guiding philosophy is like there are a
couple that i do sense i know what their
guiding philosophy is
ted cruz i would say i have a basic
sense of what his guiding philosophy is
rand paul
i would say i have a guiding sense of
what his philosophy is
um but the rest and for the most
of the lefties right now it's just oh
power what else can government do
again even even this morning
ilhan omar the the wonderful
congresswoman out of minnesota she
tweeted about that we should have 15
minimum wage and it's like well what is
the principle what is the economic
principle
the philosophic principle other than you
just want to do something and force the
government to
force private people to do something and
why not 20 instead of 15 you bigot
like why not why not it's because they
don't have principles they just have the
i oh we can just do things it doesn't
matter
what economics says or what philosophy
says or anything else
so i just thought that clip right there
it's just one
of several clips that we're going to
show you guys and maybe yeah maybe we
will do more of this
sort of thing of listening to people of
the past because maybe that can help us
frame things in the future and uh boy if
you would have ever told me 10 years ago
that that would be the type of clip from
ronald reagan that i would be playing
and saying yeah
that that's the truth that's right i
guess i'd be shocked but
here we are uh anyway guys join us on
locals reubenreport.locals.com where i
can communicate with you guys directly
without the interference
of big tech and again i just want to say
thank you to our friends at youtube
who allow us to read articles from time
magazine
who these are obviously good people who
are telling us
the truth about securing the election
and the cabal of people
who did that so thank you to the cabal
thank you to time magazine
and thank you to youtube great people oh
and
just this morning we put up uh part one
of my
interview with ayan herciale you guys
all i hope you all know ayan herciali
the incredible human rights
activist uh who i've interviewed several
times before who's become a good friend
of mine who
has just the most magnificent uh
incredible story
of like the human spirit growing up in
somalia
uh moving eventually to belgium and then
to holland and now to the united states
and
fighting for women's rights and fighting
for freedom and equality and classical
liberalism
uh and you're not going to believe who
who hates her these days yeah that's the
tolerant people on the left anyway she's
got a new book out called pray and we
talk about that and
lockdowns and and much more and she's
just just an absolute angel
uh so do check that out and of course
the full episode is already up at
reubenreport.locals.com
that's it for me people i'm on a couple
fox shows today later today or i'm on
one today but we're taping something in
advance
anyway keep an eye out if you're not
sick of me yet and uh
have a great day and by the way if i got
any of the numbers wrong at the top of
the show about the sixty percent nazis
and the
the ten percent anarchist and all that
we'll dive into those numbers we'll have
the data scientists
uh dive in even more and we'll figure
out what's what
tomorrow oh and yes it is uh fox news
prime time that's when i'm on a little
bit later today okay guys have a great
day
foreign